we are learning more about the possible
defense strategy for two high-profile
defendants in the massive College
Admission scandal actress Lori Lachlan
and her husband Massimo Gio newly rushed
by journalists in Boston yesterday
before appearing in front of a federal
judge now they face questions about
potential conflicts of interest
involving their lawyers Carter Evans is
in Boston with more on this story Carter
will the two of them be tried separately
no they're in this together they want to
be represented by the same attorney and
from what we heard in court yesterday
they're going to pursue an aggressive
legal defense strategy rather than take
any plea deals as many others have Lori
Lockland and her husband Massimo G newly
entered Tuesday's federal court hearing
with their hands locked and their heads
down
a stark contrast from their last federal
court appearance in April former federal
prosecutor Laurie Levenson I think the
more solemn demeanor tends to reflect
that they are taking this matter
seriously that they've been talking to
their lawyers they know they're going
into court this is really happening
Laurie do you still think you can win
this a trial they wouldn't answer
questions outside minutes after leaving
the courtroom where they formally waived
their rights to separate attorneys their
legal team also answered the judges
questions about a potential conflict of
interest some of the attorneys
representing the couple work at a law
firm representing another defendant
caught up in the emissions scandal who
is now cooperating with prosecutors the
judge is expected to rule on that matter
in a few days Laughlin and gia newly are
accused of paying a half million dollars
to ric singer the mastermind of the
scandal to get their two daughters who
accepted it into the university of
southern california by falsely
designating them as crew team recruits
through these court proceedings we're
also learning more about a potential
defense strategy lawyers in court
Tuesday claimed the couple was donating
to a non-profit unaware of what singer
may or may not have been doing and
that's great if the jury believes it but
the jury might not especially if other
parents said we all knew what was going
on here they're going to be back in
court on October
second but we're soon going to have the
results of another very high-profile
case
Felicity Huffman is sent to be sentenced
in just two weeks
Tony all right Carter thank you very
much